今天好多访问里面有提到
你没有那么排斥甜心的这样的一个人设或形象
我觉得很大的重点是因为他不是我的人设
他是我的个性特质之一
我觉得不管别人理不理解你
你都可以喜欢自己
拥抱自己的特质
没有环境的关系
我是长
我是姐姐
然后有一个小我五岁的弟弟
所以从小就是会比较独立的做事情
而且我爸妈就是离异的状态嘛
所以有时候就要变成小妈妈
我觉得我没有一个一定要强娶什么的心
可是我真的就是我做好我每一份我该做的事情
然后我就是用一个我不能丢脸的心情去做好
我该做的每一件事情
You ready
不止甜
我乘风破浪
20年
一起来
欢迎在华人圈大家公认的浪姐第一名
欢迎心凌
欢迎花真好
欢迎欢迎
谢谢谢谢
很开心见到你
欢迎新不心凌来
是我们今天全部换成粉红色的起来了
我说怎么多了这么多的糖果
糖果是呃
就是浪姐的奖杯就对了对
是当时的奖杯
我就觉得很像那个一个游戏
我以前一直在玩这个游戏
植物大战僵尸的游戏的奖杯
我就觉得百花齐放
所以也很谢谢心凌
因为应该是我们第一次可以看到这个奖杯
这么的cute哦
其实王心凌现象
那当然也是一种怀旧现象
你没有想过说你会带动一个现象
可以我从来也真的是没有想过这件事情
然后我就其实我们就是我自己觉得
我就是尽力去做好我该做的每一份工作
然后所以那时候有出现这样的现象的时候
其实我自己也是完全没有想到是蛮压抑的
哎呀这个现象不是说就停在2022
2023啊
王心凌要开演唱会哦
那这整个演唱会也是大家对于这个现象里面的
再次回温
包括初舞台三天内七条热搜
全网热搜指数高达46.34
然后这个一定要讲
你一票我一票
王心凌80还唱跳话题热度
这个话题就是757.7万
然后节目演唱会
爱你的单支影片播放量是高达730万哇
可以这么高的热度
这样的热度持续的时候
其实那时候你还在竞赛
对我还在竞赛
我当时还在比赛三公的比赛里头
所以我只是因为都是摄影机嘛
我只是回到化妆间的时候
然后终于有一点点时间他们在补妆
然后拿起手机
嗯嗯有这么多呃
微博热搜有这么多这这么多的话题
我自己很惊讶
可是其实我在当下其实也是没有时间笑话的
只能说很开心
然后就没有动力再继续努力
但这个现象里面还有一个
我觉得它代表的是
我觉得应该是浪姐的节目制作
但是她会很高兴
因为她本来就是观察
而且唤起了一个情怀
然后他请我来了
现在告诉大家说
其实这不只是怀旧
因为他们还在
现在我们来看一下这一个啊这一个引带
然后再继续跟新民谣爱情要多说音乐
喜欢就好的
音乐有闪躲
不偏见
不能看见
我看见可以发在小手臂
今天想爱你
不止你
一切多一点没有
今天又变晚了
爱你喜欢你
男孩请求出战
爱你就是有超凡之力
Oh baby
情
我少女的眼神
爱你爱就是有我常烦着你
好美的镜头
我想跟那些粉丝说
如果他们可以看到心凌现在在看这个视频表情
他们应该会觉得很安慰
因为我们看的是哈哈大笑
感觉心凌是一个很专注
而且好像在欣赏和分享的
感谢你看到这么多人
因为这一首歌
然后重新pick up
刚刚有个是某人的太太录的
对不对
他说我现在在听这首歌的表情
那还有人好像他回到了那个时代
对我看到这些视频的时候
其实这些视频也在呃
我那时候宿舍很忙碌的在工作
就是睡前在放松的时刻
就是在划的这些视频
我觉得这些视频呢常常歌迷都会说
我的歌带给他们一些什么温暖
我觉得这些视频也在当时
带给忙碌的我的一种抚慰
然后有很多王心凌男孩
就像有那我没有看过在洗头的
正在洗头的爸爸
然后呃看听到王心凌的歌
然后就冲到客厅
然后是正在煮菜的家庭主妇
这样就拿着锅铲就冲到客厅
其实也有很多王心凌女孩
也有一些
就是他整个模仿copy
我原本的爱你的这个MV的视频
然后从每个角度甚至他扮演我跟王少伟
就是其实就是他们都花了很多时间
去做这个影片
其实我非常的感动
也非常的谢谢
就是这像一个双向奔赴
就是我的歌曲带给他们温暖
带给他们回忆
他们的这些视频也带给我很多力量吧
可能在那时候很忙的时候
看到这些视频真的心情会比较轻松
所以我觉得这是网络时代
对艺人来讲一个很不容易的流动
对不对
我们来看一下关于王心凌现象里面的经济现象
这就是我讲的王心凌气象变成经济现象
这个芒果超媒的股票是在初舞台播出四天
股票涨了啊
ten percent哦
这个涨幅是很惊人的
这个超美股票的涨势其实是应该是投资大众
从他直播这档节目
从这个心凌女孩的现象发现说
如果我们传媒能够让大家对于以前美好时光
能够重温
从以前得到现在的力量的话
那这个传媒他们认为应该是抓对了趋势
跟大家的心理需求
对这个心理需求其实不止在浪姐之前
你有没有渐渐地感觉到那怀旧美好
这个我觉得就是可能感动的事情
有时候10年20年也不会变对
然后也许怀旧美好
会带给我们一种就是比较放松
一种安抚的感觉
也许他可以带我们暂时远离生活上的一种压力
或者是紧张和不安
让我们重温了过去曾经美好的情感跟那种快乐
所以我真的很感恩爱你
对很多人来说是有这样子的存在
然后跟当时的一些气氛和环境
我想也是有点关系
那我可以问一下
说
我们该不会把爱你
放在今年演唱会的uncle去吧
哈哈很难说
但是就是一定一定会有这一首歌
但是在什么点
我们真的是有好好想过对
所以这不能辜负已经抢到演唱会票的这个听友
我们不能在这边宣布
因为他们就要坐在里面对
怀着期待的心情
其实他自己猜对了没有
其实我自己对于这场演唱会我也是倍感压力
一直笑容微光是夜空
我们在期待夏天的喜欢
坐在巨型娃娃机吊爪上的是甜蜜教主王心凌
而今天如一日的美少女姿态也人如其名
印在衣服上了
美少女美少女
可以的衣服美少女啦
就是尽量保持美少女的心情
年纪日渐增长
这个疲劳这件事情还是会发生
所以导演麻烦你开拍快一点
MV片场布置着缤纷的色彩
指导MV的是经常和5月天蔡依林合作的阿木
导演陈奕仁
我第一次得金曲奖的时候
自然心凌颁给我的
所以姐姐是来了报恩的感觉
有点一闪一空
没有拍过很多明星啊
就是有时候大家就想说哎是我们出道了一阵子
然后是不是哎我们这样转变形象
这样可以
我们这次走的一个讨论是
既然已今天是甜心教主
那我们就这次是甜到底
然后实际上合作以后就是甜到爆炸来了
他其实是很蛮贴心的女生这样
然后他在工作的时候
其实都会照顾到所有工作人员的感受
一首歌不同角度要重复排数十次MV呈现
不过短短56分钟
却是现场近百名工作人员全力合作
一天一夜完成的作品
作为主角的王心凌停机时也不能休息
这支舞其实算是真的是我的专辑的快乐
风格比较不一样
舞蹈强度真的是比较难的意思
可以如果带着那种可以看心跳的那种手表
没有我们练舞的时候
心跳可以都可以到一百五百六
像我们刚才不是有意义的台GOPRO吗
还好他好放一整排
不然每一集一次的话不知道多少次
321行起了
宣布演唱会的记者会上
王心凌久违的面对媒体
要迈上41岁的她
让大家惊叹的是纤瘦又结实的身材
就是比我的年纪再低一点嗯
哇那也才二十二十八
大28吧
没有可以
太伤
所以说我说该运动的我还是还是保持部分
就是就是再累
我还是会push自己去
金弛有度
总是拿出最好表现的
她回顾刚出道时盯着日系唱跳美少女
与当时已经走红的蔡依林有着类似的路线
许魏源是当时爱会唱片的主管
回忆起当时打造王心凌抓到艺人本职
原来才是关键
为什么却花了那么多钱买的衣服做的造型
她明明就是一个那么漂亮的女生
可是一直都觉得好像哪里不对
在拍
当你的这首MV已经第四波了
然后张敏导演就说爱你
可以可以带你们的高中制服来
你那时候差不多20岁左右
就还是很很无违和感
他皮肤那么白
那私底下其实它很自然
没有没有什么歌啊
我想拍一个就是以学生为主
因为我觉得他很像日系的学生
黄中平导演从王心凌出道至今
和他合作过22支音乐录影带
这些打造成功艺人的军师们
抓到王心凌的甜美特质
发扬光大经典传唱的爱你也是由中平导演长进
Baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
我不想说
既然我们那时候花了那么多钱做造型
都觉得没有找到一个很对的方向
对那这这张开始我该穿
让他穿制服
所以之后再爱你的理念
就把这件事情发扬光大
我永远都记得那一天他那个歌
第一个他就是很甜美
天狗在工作现场
真的每个人都很开心
每个东西好像都对了
资历超过38年的黄忠平导演
看过形形色色的明星
面对刚出道的王心凌
也找到一套方法拍出属于王心凌的镜头语言
我第一次跟他工作时
发现他非常的紧绷
所以井柏林他处女座怕脏啊
然后怕这个人那个对齐屁之类的
可以当你都准备好时候
你去拍他的时候没有发现嗯
他没有没有办法更多了
我会弄乱他的节奏
可以每次快快快快快快快慢慢慢慢慢慢慢慢慢
你要把他节奏弄乱了
而且到了后面做一件拍一个东西
拍的到后面说他是最好
出道后的爆红唱片偶像剧双七忙碌的演艺工作
到了30岁
暂时缓下脚步
减少发片量与演戏
但是当2020年
全世界进入疫情时代
大陆实境节目乘风破浪的姐姐新起王心凌
2022年参与第三季
那个爱你的王心凌
重新唤醒观众的记忆
其实我觉得很自然
我那时候是定制的衣服嘛
然后后面因为演唱会其实也会表
表演到爱你这首歌
那时候去浪姐的时候在表演
因为是要表演爱你这首歌嘛
其实就是想要把呃原本的这个
当时大家对于我在爱你的这个美好的样子
就是带给大家在音乐里面有一些元素
可能100年1000年都不会变的
是会被喜爱的
当然最重要的是心凌还没有变
王心凌在乘风破浪的姐姐
除了开场表演制造了惊人的网络效应
后续的表现稳扎稳打
尤其被推举当队长时
更是展现出过人的稳重与责任心
这股独立又照顾人周到的个性
也如同他在演艺圈鸭子划水般不强出头
默默的努力
好喜欢这个形容
我
其实我自己在在水上面是漂亮的天鹅在
但其实下面为我们真的一路没有那演唱会吗
这样我真的是还蛮自律的
在保持自己的体能的状态
也因为这样子
所以后来去参加节目的时候
相对来说还是比较可以应付的
但还是觉得很累
自律会带来更大的自由
这样的王心凌在浪姐被看见
努力与实力爱你的制服少女甜美依旧更长
成了40岁的智慧与美丽
王心凌的乘风破浪来了
正是最好的时光
当我们回顾很快就要回顾这20年的时候
我们切分成20多岁
30多岁
然后到今年开20年的这个演唱会
才发现很难定位
你之前你会演戏嘛
然后歌手但是有其他不同的发展
151首歌
所以这次演唱会大家大概就算组曲
但他也也也没有办法容纳一半就对了
嗯就算有组曲
应该最多也是30几首歌
可以40首也没有办法装得下
昨天还在跟经纪人
还在battle某一首歌到底要放哪一首
这样你觉得在这个阶段里面
是不是30他是一个很重要的阶段
让你自己对于自己要选择什么
然后同时你的选择权在市场上
或者是在一般粉丝的心中去验证出来
你对他们的了解是对的
是在这个阶段
小时候是没有时间停下来生活的
也没有跟家人朋友相处的时间
30岁产业的变化
发批量没有像这个时候
2005年连发三张专辑
销售破百万
但重点是一年连发三张
而且我这中间还拍戏
拍的人物这部戏吧
我刚刚我们还有同仁在想说
没有没有看没有看到这一幕
超好笑的哦
所以收视率6.61
打破当年台湾偶像剧所有的记录
对当时我觉得就是一个很密集
然后全身的一个时期
这样这个时候wake可以不可以说
就你的人生来讲
其实他是一个先生存
然后再发展的阶段
所以这属于是一个努力生存的阶段
的确是的确是
而且他奠定了很多我后面的从容自在
是我们都会好奇
为什么后来你会接受大型竞赛节目的挑战
就是挑战来的时候
当时你是怎么判断的
然后点头
我觉得因为疫情疫情的关系
其实让我我跟很多各地的歌迷
就是见面的机会变少了很多
这样那因为疫情两年
大家停滞了两年
其实很单纯的
真的是觉得说好像应该要有一些不一样的舞台
好像要有更多可以跟歌迷见面的
这个这个这样的机会
现在第3年
所以那时候展开了我人生中第一次隔离
21天
我第一次隔离21天进大陆就是21天
那个时候
因为那个时候
因为疫情可能还是在一个第几阶段的高峰期
所以我们一进去就隔离21天
21天结束之后
我就今天对他一生都很难忘
因为他刚好重复了五次
21天我我从来没有在家这样子待过
21天内
那今天你都做些什么
大家一定很好奇哦
21天刚好
那时候准备出舞台的爱你
我的编曲
我的编舞
然后我的练舞我都是在那个房间玩完成
在那个时候有没有你自己的声音
或是你旁边啊
你很信任了解你的人
曾经跟你说NO
就说要不要参加这个大型竞赛
可以再考虑一下
我的经纪人当时的确有迟疑了一下
对他实力实力的一下
觉得说的确可以再观望一下
尤其像第一季其实很实际的啦
我觉得这个都可以理解
但我觉得有时候就是上天安排好的
我觉得这个timing也许我第三季才去
这个是最适合的
当我们考虑要不要投入一个竞赛的时候
我们通常是怕输
就是如果十拿九稳的话
那么我就很容易say yes
那时候你对于这个名次这件事
当你决定投入的时候
他们曾经在你心里面变成一个一个因素
还是没有
其实没有
我从来没有想过说我要去推广坤
光棍台跟白
我没有这样想
可是我只有默默的跟今天想说
我们应该会成团吧
就是既然要去的话
至少应该也要成团吧
所以我真的就是我们在那里面
其实就是我觉得我没有一个
一定要强娶什么的心
可是我真的就是我做好我每一份我该做的事情
然后我就是用一个我不能丢脸的心情去做好
我该做的每一件事
其实我觉得浪姐冠军王心凌
现在留给我们可以一直激励的
就是这一个就是那个态度跟精神啊
谢谢大家
欢迎新春爱你for you
正值暑假期间
王心凌一回到母校华冈艺校
仍然受到学弟妹列队欢迎
好你们现在的科室有哪几种
戏剧课演演艺科
演艺科分两组
音乐组跟歌舞剧组
然后还有一个舞蹈可以
就这样
我们我们一小时后呢是国西舞剧美国乐
西乐舞蹈
戏剧美术
毕业20多年重返校园
很多风景和人事物都变了
上方还特别在校园里各个led灯都打上
欢迎王心凌字样
那没有注意到没有有啊
有注意到
让我们掌声
欢迎23届戏剧科校友王心凌返回家路
有点lonely
因为现在是暑假
哈哈现在是暑假
如果不是暑假的话
我完全可以想象有多热闹
华冈艺校的高三小学弟担任起校园向导
一路上王心凌也跟我们聊着他的高中回忆
我本人以前是牛奶学结
可以我很白
很多人不知道我叫什么名字
然后可是就会叫牛奶学姐
然后以前我们也有同学就在这边
因为没有这个嘛
然后就在这边表白
小白不是对谁
我喜欢你之类的
对对对面讲的
因为学校就这么大
这么自行的
所以你就可以站在这边对大家讲
三栋楼组成的华冈艺校
位在阳明山上
校地范围不大
甚至没有一个完整的操场
王心凌最常挂在嘴上的
当年的篮球场多么迷你
如今已经变成花圃
但我们学校比较小
我们如果要运动会的话
会去借文化的大操场
运动会
OK这就是篮球场
这个花圃的大小就是我们的篮球场
你是觉得惊讶
是迷你到有点惊讶
以前坐在这边的时候
一下课探头就可以看到人家在打篮球
重回教室的王心凌
看见黑板很自然
下一个动作是拿起粉笔写下相当复古的此一游
不过签名写日期却不小心
2003啊啊速度差
诶这怎么会擦不掉啊
31了哦
2003是我出道的好
没有回到校园
就不小心掉进时光隧道
其实另一个更复古的回忆是
王心凌12岁参加综艺节目的影片
曾被挖出
一度在网络热议
原来唱跳细胞从小就养成
NO儿童舞蹈大赛
我妈妈说我就有一天看看看看看看看
就跟她说
妈妈我觉得我可以叫的比他们好
妈妈你帮我放好
可以
我可以叫
知道哪里来了日期
而我们现在所认识的唱跳甜心女神王心凌
小时候的梦想却是小时候就是看电视
那时候还小嘛
然后就觉得李秋很对
很漂亮
很聪明
然后还有没有认识你一次
所以那时候就会想
我说哇
我想要当李艳秋后来了
喜欢唱歌这件事也是成为我后来的其中一个呃
兴趣和梦想
小时候写着梦想的自己
长大后有没有长成理想中的人呢
本场40岁的过程也同时更认识了自己
其实我一点都不觉得分饰残酷诶
你会有很多学习的累积
智慧的累积
就是怎么样让自己生活的老
去的优雅又自然是最重要的
其实挺舒服自在了好一阵子的
我觉得譬如说以前他只顾他自己
他把自己做好
可是现在他到一定成熟的阶段的时候
他会发现诶
这个灯光师他是不是要稍微休息一下诶
他好像刚刚没有吃饭哦
没有我都有下来了解的话
心凌现在会去KO旁边的这些人
对那或许他以前也有
但是他可能会不好意思讲
傅植被的黄忠平导演这么说
而合作多年又年纪相仿的化妆师与法型师
既像闺蜜
又是密切工作伙伴
形容王心凌对细节极其讲究
我才是细节控啊
因为我跟心凌其实都一样
处女座
所以他讲的其实我都懂
这些细节就是为了呈现给就观众
就是一个完美的表演啊
一个完美的造型
有句话怎么赵长江魔鬼藏在细节里
越简单的东西它就是很难弄
我觉得在工作上
龟毛其实是一个专业的表现
讲究细节
龟毛才是专业的表现
王心凌这一天回到校园
正逢台风到来的日子
顶着强风
头发不时被吹乱
裙子也得时时顾好
女明星
保持美丽是众人的努力
但是当王心凌参加乘风破浪的姐姐节目露营
这些伙伴都不在身边
看着节目
同时也欣赏着王心凌的转变
其实我蛮感动的
对我就觉得哇他其实在这个节目是有成长
有进步诶
他不一样了
就是这前面疫情这两年半
其实他有在升级
那这些称赞的话
你们会不会啊
我们每天都在讲课
哇
你好漂亮
万人不理解的
身边有人理解就可以
王心凌演艺圈这20年来经历不少风雨
光是过去两段感情的新闻版面就占了不少空间
一路看着他成长的前辈们
也道出不为人知的一面
我看过她两次在大家面前落泪
都是因为被误解而流下的眼泪
可能因为他很小就进入了这个行业
他其实这一路过来遭遇到蛮多的
不管是工作上面的私人
感情上面的各式各样的挫折也好
打击也好
我觉得他已经练就了一种从容去看待这些事情
我是属于乖巧的学生
乖艺人就是可以做的
我就是会努力走向来了
本来30岁开始放慢脚步
那这一次就是乘风破浪回来
又有很多很多不同的机会
所以就还是好用感恩的心继续前行
打从出道以来
甜蜜甜心等形容词套用在他身上
经过了20年
他坦言这不是人设
而是本职
因为以前说过
80岁就是如果我你们还想听我唱歌的话
那那那我就会我还是会唱歌
如果说80岁啊
我还跳得动的话
就是还可以就是拄着拐杖唱爱你
当甜心奶奶不是也不错嘛
被爱者是前进的动力
被人需要是幸福的
那个即使到了80岁
还愿意当个甜心奶奶的王心凌
用着全唐的浓度滋润着身边的人与歌名
你现在对自己作品的那个精益求精
你自己觉得会不会跟你合作的人都发现
你现在对于这个作品的期待非常的高
所以你愿意投资很长的这个时间来琢磨
其实后来自己都一直有参与专辑
然后其实参与专辑的时候
我们其实都是这样
然后就说那精益求精的心琴心态是一样的
不过真的就是本来今天是要
本来今天是要录完最后一首歌
然后真的也是因为那个歌词还是想要调整
所以后来还是没有录完
对可以
但我现在都会很正面的告诉自己
反正就是好事多磨
就是反正就是大家都是想把事情做好
这样其实你是很独立的人物
跟观众朋友讲
刚刚我们在开录之前
哎
因为我们要调整这个心凌的妈妈哈
要呃换边别换边
别的时候这个麦头你就要重新打开诶
我跟你讲
这是我录了13年来了
我第一次有来宾要换麦头的时候
诶
没说什么
就自己自己拆开来自己弄
自己重新上下别的友啦
心凌是自己把那个麦头拆开
然后自己呃弄了啊
好好了
可以了可以了可以了没有
我是看这个MAL
我还会拆另外比较复杂的meal
我就无法了没有
我只是观察
他说这真的跟我在一准备要访问心凌前
我看到很多人说
其实你自己也说你是一个独立性很高的人
从哪些事情你愿意跟华人观众分享
你是一个独立性很高的人
可以自己能做的事情都习惯自己做
其实我觉得我应该是因为我家庭环境的关系
所以某个部分来说我是独立的对
但是如果有有人可以依妈妈在的时候啊
哦就是或是表姐在所有人可以依赖的时候
我还是会依赖
可以因为环境的关系
我是长姐
我是姐姐
然后有一个小我五岁的弟弟
所以从小就是会比较独立的做事情
尤其我妈妈就是离异的状态嘛
所以有时候就要变小妈妈
所以某个程度有一些部分我是独立的
再加上嗯其实小时候拍戏的时候
很多东西也是自己来了
那后来就是到浪姐的时候
就又开始就是什么都要做
就一身兼数职
就是什么要做
所以包含这些卖的这些事情
就是反正我就觉得反正这样比较快
没有关系
我能来我就自己来
那我真的我不没有做不来就再麻烦你们这样
所以人生有时候他很像一个倒流
我听你讲
我感觉20岁时候出道的
你
其实你可能比一般人
相对在要判断和处理事情上要来的早熟一些
但现在40岁
每个人都说爱你
今天录音的时候
你帮我仔细看看
那个王心凌会不会看起来真的像人家说的
像20岁也没有那么夸张
他是一个道理
就人生是一个道理
以前你会觉得自己要比较早熟嘛
在小孩子的时候进入这一行
进入这一行其实就是懵懵懂懂边做边学
但是需要比较早熟
是因为家庭环境的关系
我们回到讲浪结束
你说你其实你变得更独立了
因为那是一个争分夺秒的时间利用
对不对
是一个很新的经验
就觉得说嗯其实原来快40岁也可以
也可以被逼成这样
席卷欧洲
西欧国家水母同第三季的浪姐
从王心凌心心里面去看
其实那个过程要多努力
在实践压缩上说
有时候忙到连麦克风都不能够拆下
就没有这个时间要上厕所的时候
哦可以跟我们聊一下吗
这个过程啊
我们每一次去进去录音
至少我这一期是这就是大概三天三夜
五天五夜
有公演的那一段就是五天五夜
可是我觉得那个时间的利用
跟那个工作量根本是加倍的
所以你说五天当十天用的这种概念
差不多是这样
所以啊然后这整个环境只有厕所跟换装间
没有镜头
然后只要有人在的地方
基本上那些机器都不会停止
它会收录你所有所有的音乐的声音
就算没有影像
但他有声音去去去李咏这样
他是这么哦这么真实的一个呃是这样的真人秀
然后所以你也不太会有机会可以放松
那我们要化妆
我们要呃练舞
要练歌
要开舞台
会议定妆
要彩排
要拍杂志
就是那是三天三夜
五天五夜里面要做的很多很多的事情
所以其实我是我的朋友
参参与上一季的姐姐陈敏
有时候说最后你会就是会放弃才买
我要当王心凌艺人本领
我要当自己的助理
准备所有的东西
从underway安全裤
袜子的长短
就是你工作所有需要用到的东西要自己准备
然后后来当队长
就是还要当变经纪人去协调大家的时间
然后我要解决我自己在舞台上
比如说呃队长突然会需要比别人多一首歌
就是我要解决我自己在表演上的一些问题
我要去处理之外
然后又是队长
还要去协助队友
当一对一的私教课教吴谨言小姐
因为她是演员
姐姐嘛
只要她唱歌
但因为她很努力
所以就是要做的事情真的很多
但是可以我觉得这是不一样的一种体验啊
就因为时间的压缩
所以这个倍量是一个很新的经验
对是一个很新的经验
就觉得说嗯其实原来快40岁也可以
也可以被逼成这样
所以是这个挑战我要说是很过瘾的一部分
还是你发现你自己有这样你没有发现的潜能的
让你觉得很回味的一部分
我应该是说我觉得他是一个很特别的体验
然后嗯还是会很回忆起
就是过去的那段经历
不管是跟工作同事或者是跟之前的队友禁言
阿娇阿莎就是回忆起这些东西
其实都还是很开心
很美好的
我们到现在都还是私下会有群众还是会联系
就是还是很珍惜这一份
曾经一起努力打拼了这个时光
但是我真的觉得就是可以的
就是带一次就够了的美好回忆对
然后呢
今天我还有一个问题是封面
大家叫我一定要问
第一个是说你坐在那个王心凌对面
你可以帮我们看清楚
他是不是真的看起来像20几岁
还有一个就是保养之道
哈哈因为我在看天下杂志访问姓名
然后他特别提到说王心凌很坦然地说
其实做甜心奶奶对我来讲也没有什么不可以
所以这个保养跟年龄对于你来说
你是怎么样的去看待跟全身保养
我觉得真的都是老生常谈
就是卸妆清洁
敷脸保湿
你的睡眠时间
大概平均一天要让自己一定要睡到几小时
我从去年开始发现好的睡眠品质非常的重要
就是去年食宿要攻实数
我觉得是睡眠品质
有时候时速我们工作的关系就是很难抓
时速度会有多少可以睡眠的品质
我觉得对于身体的恢复来讲
我觉得有很明显的感受
你累的时候会不会失眠
因为大家想知道王心凌是不是跟你我一样的
你累的时候会不会失联
或者说你以前你也会会啊
我其实我其实去年从姐姐那个时候也常常失眠
到现在也常常失眠
就在想工作的事情
就是没有压力
对听不下来了
所以我最近也是蛮长失联
所以才会觉得最近真的深的深深觉得
睡眠品质很重要好
所以他是分享的秘诀
就是这个你可以年龄的看法呢
哦因为你今天很坦然的
所以我都到处可以看到
听到80岁的甜心奶奶也可以
你对年龄的看法是什么
我想这个对很多观众朋友来讲
他们也想听
你就是其实我像有些人说
你在不在意说你的年龄
其实我不在意
因为就算我在意的话
大家网络上也都查得到
可以不如就坦然接受
而且我觉得本来就是年龄就是会这样
这是一件自然而然的事情
所以你应该是去坦然接受
去想受自己每一个年龄的变化
对啊
然后我希望我自己以后可以优雅的老去
我觉得是最重要
我们刚刚看过了
那个从小小时候出道到现在的版子
我觉得他就是一个实力的累积
然后实力本身带来了很大的变化
我们来看一下这一次里面啊
王心凌合唱了一首歌
然后这首歌让很多
也许以前没有跟着王心凌走演艺路的人才
发言说啊
先明是真的会唱
这首歌是
你跟谭会不会都是11代长江啊
那时候为什么会确定这个目标来挑战这首歌
它的难度其实不只是高音
对不对
我知道这首歌对于观众来讲其实很新鲜
就是很意想不到
对我来说也是挑战
可以其实我心里面知道
那是我可以驾驭
有把握的挑战
然后上海这个公园是我所有公园里面
最轻松的一公
因为只需要好好唱歌
我觉得对于薇薇来讲
应该也是
因为我们在那之后
我们就是队长
然后可能还要准备两个舞台
两个表演
然后都要跳舞
这是这是唯一一次公演
我们可以好好好好面对一首歌曲
好好唱歌的义工
你刚刚有一句话很打动我
你说其实选这首歌
你知道你自己可以驾驭的
它带来这么多的惊喜
我惊喜里面还有很多人佩服说哦
原来他是可以唱这样一个难度
或者通俗讲哦
心凌可以飙到这么稳的这个高音
这个过程里面是不是很多人对于你的歌唱实力
或者其实你可以驾驭不同类型的歌曲表演
其实还没有这么的了解
可以就是也是很谢谢
就是去年这样的一段时光
让大家看到不一样的我
因为实际上就是在我的专辑里面
突然选一首这样子的歌曲
可能也会蛮跳痛
就是不太有机会唱到这样子的歌
然后反而是因为节目
所以你没有任何包袱的
可以去做不一样的表演
对可以我们对这个演唱会的期待只有有身高
我就发现这个心凌是对任何挑战都举重若轻
处之泰然的人
甜心自从这个心凌被封为甜心教主之后
这个词好像用在谁的身上有过吗
杨丞琳有没有被灌过甜心
在他输出到时候就忘记可以
这很可爱
你就很流行教主可爱教主
甜心甜甜心
甜蜜教主
百变教主
还有什么
那时候很流行
教主对没有
这个甜心教主到现在江湖上呢还是东方不败
哈哈甜心
这个有的人会觉得说啊
甜心限制了你
限制了我们对你的想象
事实上也不尽然
所以你对甜心今天好多访问里面有提到嗯
你没有那么排斥甜心的这样的一个人设或形象
嗯我觉得很大的重点是因为他不是我的人设
他是我的个性特质之一
我觉得不管别人理不理解你
你都可以喜欢自己
拥抱自己的特质
那这是我的特质之一
它不应该是我的包袱
嗯所以这也是我觉得是不是你的一个
我觉得是一种很成熟的一个豁达
就是呃不因为别人怎么看你
你会觉得自己在这个框架里面去呈现自己
只要那个跟你自己的特质不违和就OK的
对
其实在过程中我们也有做过很多不同的尝试
的确就是这些尝试其实还是我
我还是不希望他不像我自己
我还是希望他不是违背王心凌这个人
而去尽力去做的尝试
嗯对然后所以我们也唱了山海
因为山海让大家就是欧
王心凌也可以唱这样子的歌
然后因为这个节目对这种真人秀的录制方式
会让大家看到我
私底下王心凌其实是怎么样准备工作
准备舞台就是比较大家看不到的那一面
那另外一方面就是
其实你说你自己一直其实是希望
做个有肩膀的人
你刚刚提过
你小时候照顾那个小你五岁的弟弟
你是真的就是有照顾他
就是说在他的生活起居上面
就因为呃本来父母没有离异的时候
可以有时候他们工作比较晚
那真的就是会要我要照顾弟弟
我其实五岁的时候
弟弟就是还是小婴儿
然后我就要在家里
但是一小段时间就是看顾着他
时间到了
我要跑上楼上去五楼找邻居太太帮我喂弟弟
魏魏魏
弟弟还没有上小一没有对
然后后来我们家是在我小二
小三的时候离异离异
后来我跟弟弟就跟着妈妈
那妈妈还是要工作
所以我觉得有时候会像小妈妈这样子
然后然后就嗯自己试图煮菜这样
然后弟弟就会很贴心对我说好不好吃
他说好吃
后来我想每次怎么都说好吃
后来就问他说
那你下次还想不想吃
就不想吃
我就知道那个是不好吃
所以小时候是因为这样的环境
就是还算蛮独立的
但我觉得有肩膀的人
其实像后来有时候跟弟弟在说
就是我觉得我们要懂得去为我们的选择
负责跟承担
然后遇到问题的时候
我们要有去面对和解决的能力
这是这是一种独立吗
这是一种独立
而且这是我觉得就是有肩膀的人
就是我其实自己是这样子的人
所以从20岁就进入演艺圈
她绝对是一个相对复杂的行业跟环境
但是你刚刚讲说
既然你那时候自己选择了
所以后来你在碰到一些挑战甚至困难的时候哦
会比较不舒服的事情时候
其实你是自己啊自己去承担
对不对
嗯对这就是对自己的选择去承担对
但但
但反正我觉得感情啊
情感啊跟父母的爱
跟兄弟姐妹的
跟朋友的爱就是爱这件事情是是交流的
然后呃接收跟给予都很重要
因为刚刚在一开始你们没有听到
我就想说我要把这四个字记下来
他刚刚讲的相互奔赴
我如果没有听错的话
我就非常喜欢这四个字
而且是我啊第一次在艺人的口里面听到
所以我觉得相互奔赴
应该也是他可以诠释你出道20年的心情
然后人生40岁这个阶段的心情也是面对世界
或是面对你所珍惜的人
希望都是一个啊爱的流动
都是一个相互奔赴的不对
所以这也是很多跟你想
会从从你小时候跟你一起喜欢你
一直到现在的原因
其实你没有很多时间
真正的除了开演唱会
失职的跟歌迷游有互动吧
一本在网络的时代对
虽然就是嗯因为网络的时代
我可以看到很多他们的视频
或是他们会在我的power下面做一些留言
可以实际上很实质的交流
互动的确是没有这么多
但是我觉得他可以
他们可以从从我们在表演上
就是一些细节上
我们给予他们的反馈
我觉得他们会接收到我的歌迷
其实也是一直告诉我
他没有感受到我跟他们是在相互奔赴
然后互相陪伴
每次想对于所有的艺术创作
或者演艺工作人来说
最嗯跟歌迷最直接的互动去透过作品
这次有演唱会啊
心凌是喊出了最高规格
全唐启动
在一起过20年的呼唤
那个糖是糖果的糖
呵呵好
最高贵的全场启动
在今天我们的这类节目
最后
其实我们一起期待这演唱会呈现在我们面前
那当然有很多要属于保密的部分
怎么办呢
就希望将来有机会再邀请到心凌跟大家聊
可以谈一下
总的来说最高规格跟全糖启动
在这次疫情后的这个演唱会啊
你希望传递的是一个什么样的嗯
王心凌精神
还有跟歌迷
希望那个晚上是怎么样的一个气氛跟情景
这次的巡演的主题叫徐格海
但我的应该可以说吧
我专辑里面有一首歌就叫做sugar high
然后20周年
所以我希望大家都可以来呃
有一种庆祝的感觉
然后可以在这个晚上得到很多美好的回忆
跟一种放松对
然后一起庆祝我们的20周年好
这个蛋糕上的20的蜡烛吹过之后再往下
在戏剧我们刚刚提到歌唱
在戏剧或演艺事业
其他各方面
你自己最新的想象是什么
最后可以跟我们分享一下
其实说真的
就是这次的新专辑跟接下来的训练
已经排到明年了
所以其实新的巡演会占据这次工作哦
很大的很长的时间
但是至少到明年对
所以戏剧真的是很久没有参与了
我现在也只能用一种就是随缘的事情
欢迎大家在常常回去寻找
那个让你们难忘的微笑
帕斯塔或其他在里面去
看到有一部分特质依旧保有那个甜心
不变的心凌
大家可以一直的回味
而且一直的关注
现在心凌的发展
今天非常谢谢心凌来看板人物
感谢感谢期待演唱会
也期待你的专辑带给我们更多更多的感谢
跟心心
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢大家
谢谢很开心
今天见到念华姐
很开心
今天和大家分享了那么多心里面的想法
接下来我有很多新的巡演
会到很多城市
希望大家都可以来看
王心凌
2023苏格海世界巡回演唱会20周年
希望大家都可以来一起庆祝参与我的喜悦
18斤